scp-096 versus scp-166  the mass murdering shy guy versus the  teenage goddess of nature who will win  out life or death let's find out the shy  guy is an almost unstoppable monster who  will relentlessly hunt down and kill  anybody who sees its face ripping and  tearing through any obstacles in the way  scp-166 is a faithful young lady with  power over the forces of nature who has  employed these powers to fight against  and immobilize as cp 682 in a previous  battle while the nature powers of 166  may slow down  scp-096 the monster will never ever give  up eventually it would get to her and  punish her for seeing its face we think  scp-096 would still take home the win on  this one